please welcome the very funny eric andre
[Applause]
so
have a seat eric thank you america
[Laughter]
and he danced with me and he danced with
me
and he danced with me and he danced
i like that the band knows the music
that goes with that
instantaneously can you tell we
rehearsed that for an
hour you're not afraid to take risks in
your comedy which is always a good thing
you have been going to places on your
show where you are clearly not
welcome yeah and getting into trouble
yeah that's always the kind of thing
where
there's got to be some point where you
think okay i know this is going to be
funny maybe later on but i'm kind of
scared right now that i might really get
in trouble
terrified terrified i mean my throat was
touching my butthole in the middle of my
body
[Applause]
yeah i got arrested actually how did you
get arrested i got arrested i dressed up
like a frat boy and i went to a town
hall meeting
in rancho cucamonga actually have the
clip as a cool advice this is you okay
so this is a place where people are
making real serious proposals yeah
they're making proposals about the parks
and recreation department blah blah blah
or whatever okay none of that movement
no that was you
uh rolling dice yeah yeah i was rolling
dice and uh
yeah uh i think we have this video and
you got in some
some serious trouble
[Music]
all here i appreciate the opportunity to
speak to you this morning i've got five
items that i'd
like to discuss really quickly thank you
a lot of times cars are still out there
at 7 00 7 30 at night
and it's just a nightmare for us
hey guys vote for me for class president
and i'll put beer in the water fountains
and cameras in the girls locker rooms
sir would you please us take a seat
don't tease me
me bro don't change me bro
so they take you out in the hallway take
me outside all the sheriffs around me
and they're grilling me they're giving
me sobriety tests and i'm just
nailing them i'm doing the alphabet
backwards like z y x w
v u t s r q p o n m l k j i
h g f e d c b a
let's see you do it bad boy bring it in
harvard i can't do it oh you've been
drinking
yeah i've been drinking so
then they're really furious they're like
what's your name funny man i didn't want
to tell them my name so i was like
uh john they're like what's your last
name john and i was like
coltrane and then so they so they start
typing in their computer
like not coming up in the system call
train
and then that's great
and then they brought me to jail they
didn't bring me to like the little rinky
dink dui
drunk tank they brought me to like the
big scary msnbc prison documentary jail
yes and everybody looked like a
background actor from breaking bad
or like a former oakland raider they all
had like tear drop tattoos on the whites
of their eyes
yeah and they're all going around like
training stories like oh what are you in
for
and one guy was like i'm in for heroin
and another guy was like oh i
punched my grandma in the face or
whatever then they got to me and i was
like
mad nervous i was like uh uh what me i
uh
i i told i went to a town hall meeting
dressed like a frat boy and while the
mayor was speaking
i ran up to the podium and said vote for
me for class president and i will put
beer in the water fountains and cameras
in the girls
locker rooms go bobcats and there was
like five seconds of the most
uncomfortable
butthole clenching silence i've ever
felt my life and then they just
erupted into like death comedy jam they
were just like you're hilarious
i just took turns like macho man randy
said
and we all celebrated with a cold glass
of toilets